No vengáis, no vengáis.
Queridos amigos, amigas, las relaciones entre
Estados Unidos y Latinoamérica nunca fueron
fáciles, no siempre han sido cordiales y
no está del todo claro cuál de las dos partes
ha tenido habitualmente menos ilusión por
ir de la mano con la otra.
Dicho de otra forma, esta relación ha sido
siempre menos romántica que una película
de Sylvester Stallone.
Desde principios del siglo XX el único interés
que Washington ha tenido en sus vecinos del
sur ha sido casi en exclusiva el de alinearlos
a sus propios intereses geopolíticos e ideológicos.
Algo que se vio reforzado a partir de los
años sesenta con la llegada del comunismo
a Cuba en plena Guerra Fría.
Desde entonces, Washington no dudó en apoyar
a cuantos dictadores, grupos paramilitares
o malhechores estuvieran dispuestos a cuadrarse
ante el tío Sam.
Fuera como fuese , lo cierto es que el papel
o la injerencia de Estados Unidos ha pasado
por diferentes etapas.
La última la del expresidente Donald Trump
fue quizás una de las más distantes de todas.
Y eso que dejó declaraciones como esta:
("Cuando Venezuela sea libre, y Cuba sea libre,
y Nicaragua sea libre, este se convertirá
en el primer hemisferio libre en toda la historia
de la humanidad.
Ha llegado la última hora del socialismo
en nuestro hemisferio [...] Los días del
socialismo están contados.
No solo en Venezuela sino en Nicaragua y en
Cuba”.
Donald Trump)
Sin embargo, llegada la hora de la verdad…
Cómo expresarlo.
Digamos que Trump nunca llegó a manifestar
mucho interés por Latinoamérica.
Al menos no un interés mayor que el que tiene
un vegano por un chuletón de kilo y medio.
Pero, un momento, porque ahora las cosas han
cambiado: hay un nuevo inquilino en la Casa
Blanca.
Un presidente con ideas y experiencias muy
distintas y del que se espera intente jugar
de nuevo las cartas de la disputada competición
latinoamericana.
Por eso, en VisualPolitik nos hemos hecho
unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Qué cambios puede traer consigo la nueva
Administración?
¿Más allá de la cuestión mexicana que
tiene un rol propio, cuáles son los temas
clave que están sobre la mesa?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿Qué pasa con China?
¿Volverá Latinoamérica a convertirse en
el campo de juego de una nueva contienda global?
Atentos.
(Por cierto, si queréis saber más sobre
Latinoamérica no os perdáis Latampolitik,
nuestra newsletter dedicada exclusivamente
a esta región.
Os dejo toda la información en la descripción.)
(MOCHILA AL HOMBRO)
Amigos, durante las últimas elecciones presidenciales
de los Estados Unidos, dos de cada tres latinos
votaron por Joe Biden.
Sin embargo, no, esa no es ni mucho menos
la principal razón por la que se espera que
Latinoamérica adquiera más peso en la política
exterior norteamericana.
Lo cierto es que Joe Biden es el inquilino
del Despacho Oval que más conocimiento tiene
sobre la región.
Para que os hagáis una idea, tan sólo durante
su etapa como Vicepresidente de Barack Obama,
Biden visitó la región ni más ni menos
que en 16 ocasiones.
Nunca antes un presidente o un vicepresidente
había visitado tantas veces América Latina.
Y...
Lógicamente eso no es algo anecdótico.
Si Donald Trump consideraba a la región como
algo insignificante, por así decirlo, una
especie de pozo que solo le daba quebraderos
de cabeza, para Biden es un escenario en juego
que además conoce de primera mano.
Y para bien o para mal eso es algo que se
ha manifestado desde el primer momento.
Por ejemplo, ha nombrado Juan Sebastían Gonzalez,
un tipo nacido en Colombia, como el nuevo
Director de Asuntos Hemisféricos en el Consejo
de Seguridad Nacional, esto es, el hombre
fuerte del Presidente para los asuntos de
Latinoamérica.
Pero, por supuesto, los cambios no se limitaron
a un nombramiento.
Prácticamente nada más aterrizar en la Casa
Blanca el nuevo equipo anunció cambios importantes:
(En primer lugar la Administración Biden
abandona la política planteada por Trump
de un segundo eje del mal integrado por Venezuela,
Cuba y Nicaragua.
Lo que, según parece, significa que la cuestión
venezolana o cubana ya no serán la única
preocupación de Washington.
Es decir, para entendernos, que formar parte
del frente común contra este eje del mal
ya no eximirá de las posibles críticas del
gigante norteamericano.
Eso es por ejemplo lo que ocurrió nada más
llegar al poder el nuevo equipo de la Secretaría
de Estado cuando hizo público que seguía
de cerca el intento del Congreso de Guatemala
de colocar en la Corte Constitucional a un
juez acusado de obstrucción a la justicia;
o también cuándo han manifestado su inquietud
por la violencia contra activistas por los
derechos humanos en Colombia.)
En segundo lugar, se anunció que Cuba será
excluida de la lista de estados patrocinadores
del terrorismo.
Luego veremos la cuestión con más detalle.
Y la tercera decisión que rápidamente tomó
el nuevo equipo de gobierno fue acordar la
concesión del Estatus de protección temporal
a más 300 mil venezolanos exiliados.
Es decir, en otras palabras, que todo apunta
a que veremos una Administración mucho más
activa, exigente e intrusiva en los asuntos
locales.
Pero, por supuesto, los dos primeros temas,
los dos temas estrella en la agenda latinoamericana
de absolutamente todos los presidentes de
Estados Unidos desde hace ya varias décadas
no son otros que la inmigración y la lucha
contra el narcotráfico.
Así que la primera pregunta que nos podemos
hacer es, ¿Exactamente, cuál es la posición
de la Administración Biden respecto a la
inmigración y el narcotráfico?
Pues… Atentos.
(INMIGRACIÓN Y NARCOS AL CUADRADO)
Donald Trump fue uno de los presidentes de
Estados Unidos más hostiles a la inmigración
de las últimas décadas.
Y eso es algo que Joe Biden ha dicho por activa
y por pasiva se va a terminar.
Claro que la consecuencia de lanzar ese tipo
de mensajes puede ser exactamente la que no
quieres:
(22 de marzo: La frontera sur saturada: así
se llegó a la primera crisis migratoria de
la era Biden.
El País)
Amigos, el impacto de la pandemia en países
ya de por sí muy pobres junto a la nueva
posición de la Administración Biden sobre
la inmigración y algunas medidas que han
tomado como por ejemplo la suspensión de
la política “quedate en México”, que
obligaba a los solicitantes de asilo en Estados
Unidos a permanecer en el país mexicano hasta
regularizar su situación han provocado una
nueva ola migratoria.
(17 de marzo del 2021: “Estamos en vías
de registrar más personas en la frontera
sur que en los últimos 20 años”.
Alejandro Mayorkas, jefe del Departamento
de Seguridad Interior.)
(“Lo ven como el presidente de los migrantes,
y por eso muchos sienten que van a llegar
a Estados Unidos”.
Andrés Manuel López Obrador, Presidente
de México)
Por ejemplo, la decisión de no deportar a
los menores no acompañados, pues, ha provocado
que estos lleguen en masa.
(“La cifra de menores no acompañados que
llegan a EE.
UU. marca récords.
Cerca de 19.000 niños migrantes sin acompañantes
llegaron a Estados Unidos tras cruzar la frontera
con México, durante marzo.
Se trata de la mayor cifra mensual que jamás
se haya registrado en el país”.
France24)
Y claro, es entonces cuando de repente nos
encontramos con mensajes como estos:
("No vengan", pide Joe Biden a migrantes.
El presidente estadounidense instó a los
indocumentados que protagonizan la última
oleada migratoria que se queden en sus países.DW)
Pero, la
pregunta es, ¿Qué planes concretos tiene
en mente el nuevo gobierno para enfrentarse
a este problema?
Y otra cuestión importante: ¿Por qué demonios
hablamos de inmigración si este es un vídeo
sobre Biden y Latinoamérica?
Pues queridos amigos la razón tiene que ver
con la nueva estrategia de la Casa Blanca.
Digamos que el nuevo planteamiento del gobierno
de Estados Unidos es que tanto la inmigración
como en buena medida la proliferación del
narcotráfico tiene que ver esencialmente
con la situación local de procedencia.
Esto es, con la falta de oportunidades, la
ausencia de seguridad y la poca fortaleza
de las instituciones locales para hacer frente
a los problemas.
Y entienden que es exactamente en estos puntos
dónde tienen que trabajar.
Por ejemplo, cuando hablamos de inmigración,
además de México, hablamos necesariamente
de lo que Estados Unidos denomina “el triángulo
norte”: Guatemala, El Salvador y Honduras.
Son 3 de los países más pobres de Latinoamérica.
Países con problemas muy pero que muy serios:
altísimas tasas de violencia, pandillas,
corrupción masiva e incluso políticos con
lazos directos con el narcotráfico.
Ahí está, por ejemplo, el caso del mismísimo
presidente de Honduras, Juan Orlando Hernández,
del que ya os hemos hablado en varias ocasiones
en VisualPolitik.
(De esta forma el planteamiento de Washington
es que si las condiciones de vida mejoran
en estos países, entonces, habrá menos inmigración
irregular y también será más fácil controlar
el narcotráfico.
Por eso Biden apuesta por retomar la estrategia
que Barack Obama puso en marcha en 2016: la
conocida como Alianza para la Prosperidad
del Triángulo Norte.
Un programa que recibió 750 millones de dólares
en 2016 pero que luego bajo la Administración
Trump se fue reduciendo año tras año.
En total el presupuesto asignado superó los
2.000 millones de dólares entre 2016 y 2020.
Un dinero que supuestamente se utilizó para
financiar proyectos para impulsar el desarrollo
y mejorar las condiciones de vida locales.)
Pues bien, ahora Joe Biden ha presentado un
plan para impulsar de nuevo esta política
con 4.000 millones de dólares durante cuatro
años.
1.000 millones por año.
Un plan al frente del cual ha situado a la
vicepresidenta Kamal Harris, que es exactamente
lo que Obama hizo con el propio Biden.
(“Cuando fui vicepresidente, me centré
en proporcionar la ayuda necesaria para abordar
estas causas fundamentales de la migración.
Ayudó a mantener a la gente en sus propios
países en lugar de obligarla a marcharse.
Nuestro plan funcionó”.
Joe Biden.)
El problema, amigos, es que no está claro
que el programa realmente funcionara.
La idea tenía sentido pero lo cierto es que
los resultados fueron muy pobres.
Durante 2019 y 2020 las inmigración a Estados
Unidos se ha disparado de nuevo y, por ejemplo,
en Guatemala, un país que ha recibido más
de 1.600 millones de dólares en ayuda de
Estados Unidos durante los últimos 10 años,
los índices de pobreza han aumentado, la
desnutrición es un problema real y la corrupción
campa a sus anchas.
Quizás el problema es que el plan estuviera
mal planteado.
Por ejemplo, se calcula que las empresas que
lo pilotaban se quedaban con cerca del 50%
del presupuesto en conceptos como salarios
y gastos burocráticos.
(“Es un negocio.
Los mismos ejecutores ganan los contratos
una y otra vez, a pesar de haber sido malos
ejecutores en el pasado, sin mostrar ningún
nivel de impacto y sin cambiar nada”.
Carlos Ponce, Profesor de Gestión Empresarial
en la Universidad de Columbia)
Pero de todo esto hablaremos largo y tendido
en un próximo vídeo que ya estamos preparando
y que estamos convencidos no te dejará indiferentes,
así que, ya sabes, no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik si aún no lo has hecho.
Luego, en Colombia, el epicentro junto a México
del problema de los narcóticos, Biden ha
pedido al Congreso elevar hasta los 453 millones
de dólares anuales la ayuda anual para luchar
contra el narcotráfico.
Una cantidad sustancialmente superior a la
media de 330 millones destinada por Trump
durante sus últimos 3 presupuestos.
Una política de dotación de fondos que encaja
con esa visión más intervencionista que
parece defender la nueva Casa Blanca en su
continente hermano.
Pero, por supuesto, aquí no queda todo.
(SUEÑOS DE CARACAS Y LA HABANA)
La política hacia Cuba es siempre una de
las más controvertidas y con más coste político
de toda la diplomacia norteamericana.
No olvidéis, sin ir más lejos, lo que ocurrió
en las pasadas elecciones presidenciales del
2020, cuando la minoría cubana en Florida
le dio la espalda al Presidente y se inclinó
mayoritariamente por Trump.
Y lo hizo porque Biden está dispuesto a retomar
la política de distensión que en su día
ya puso en marcha Barack Obama y que fue conocida
como la “diplomacia del Béisbol”.
Sin embargo, parece que Biden aprendió la
lección cuándo Obama tendió la mano al
régimen castrista en busca de un cambio y
este casi le muerde la mano.
De esta forma, parece que la posición será
bastante pasiva: es decir, que muevan ficha
en la Habana y sean ellos quienes demuestren
activamente que están dispuestos a iniciar
una cierta transición política y económica.
Aún así, lo que si quiere hacer la Casa
Blanca es dejar la puerta abierta.
(El equipo de Biden tiene decidido revertir
la inclusión de Cuba en la lista de países
patrcinadores del terrorismo que llevó a
cabo en sus últimas días de mandato la Administración
Trump.
Asimismo también se da por hecho que frenará
la puesta en marcha de la Ley Helms-Burton
cuyo título III permite que los ciudadanos
norteamericanos demanden a las empresas internacionales
que utilicen o se beneficien de las propiedades
confiscadas por el régimen de Fidel Castro.
Esta es una norma, que fue suspendida desde
1996, por todos los presidentes pero que Trump
decidió activar como medida en 2019,
Asimismo, ante la mala situación de la economía
cubana y para impulsar la apertura, el equipo
de Biden pretende levantar los límites que
existen a las remesas y los viajes a la isla.)
Y respecto a Venezuela, tres cuartas partes
de lo mismo.
Que sean ellos quienes muevan ficha.
Pero dicho esto, más allá del cada vez más
debilitado bloque cubano-venezolano y junto
a la política respecto a Centro América
hay otra cuestión que preocupa y mucho en
Washington:
Ni más ni menos que el miedo a la influencia
china.
(LA CONQUISTA DE ORIENTE)
Si hay un tema que últimamente hace saltar
todas las alarmas en Washington ese es precisamente
el de la influencia china en el resto del
mundo.
No importa si hablamos del Pacífico, de África,
de Europa o de Latinoamérica.
Y lo cierto es que en los últimos años la
influencia china en esta región no ha parado
de crecer.
China devora literalmente las materias primas
de la región,ha invertido mucho en sectores
como la energía, las autopistas o los puertos.
Y eso parece ser lo que ahora Biden quiere
contrarrestar.
(“La estrategia de Biden será ofrecer financiamiento
alternativo para sectores críticos de infraestructura
que incluya aspectos claves como las telecomunicaciones”.
Benjamin Gedan, director del Programa Latinoamericano
del Wilson Center)
Sin embargo, un momento, porque la jugada
más importante para contrarrestar el creciente
peso de China en la región y al mismo tiempo
apoyar a los países más próximos a Estados
Unidos no sería otro que regresar al TPP,
ahora conocido como CPTPP.
El acuerdo de libre comercio transpacífico
más avanzado al que por ejemplo, como ya
os contamos, incluso el Reino Unido ha pedido
su adhesión.
Y eso es, exactamente, con lo que ahora se
especula en Washington.
ntegrarse de nuevo en este acuerdo comercial
tendría dos consecuencias directas: un espaldarazo
a la Alianza del Pacífico, cuyos integrantes
forman parte de este acuerdo y estrechar los
lazos entre Estados Unidos y Latinoamérica.
Además supondría poner punto y final a una
de las políticas más características de
la era Trump: la del proteccionismo comercial.
Queridos amigos, amigas, estos son los principales
temas que están en la agenda latinoamericana
de Joe Biden.
Y llegados hasta aquí, pregunta para tí:
¿Qué crees que supondrá la Administración
Biden para Latinoamérica?
¿Cuál será su influencia?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
ya sabes, si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima